so Drake is making headlines and it's
not for a new song y'all musically star
Jacob sutorius may or may not have
dissed the rapper in this new song
alright for those of you who aren't
familiar with Jacob he is a 16 year old
singer who recently dated Milly Bobby
Brown the actress has been very public
about her friendship with Drake and has
said you know he gives her relationship
advice a lot so take a listen to Jacobs
new song catch that girl I want to give
you more than good advice which is why I
believe you fans to believe this is
about Drake I am gonna throw it out
there that I would not come for Drake he
will teach you a lot
Jake up I'm sorry but Drake has enough
beef that's the thing I also think Drake
doesn't have time to deal with this no I
don't think he would care oh yeah I also
said on LeBron James show on HBO that he
doesn't have time for diss tracks that's
not what he wants to be known about and
I'm sorry Jacob you're 16 years old
bloody just enjoy it enjoy your fame
enjoy making music all your loving this
tea today yeah you are but of course we
know Lilly and as you mentioned Millie
and Drakkar longtime friends I think
he's just pokin and have a little bit of
fun yeah I wouldn't read too much into
it I feel like the the lyrics I don't
think there's not to diss Jacob but I
don't think the lyrical depth is there
oh I said it not me before I get trolled
on Twitter and musically and all that oh
we like the song though Jake we do
you
[Music]